I got into Twitter because I pulled me
in I was already used in the product I
was already believer but I would not
have made that first bet had not had
I've not pulled me in but the later bets
I made you know where I raised multiple
funds that invest just in Twitter I'll
take credit for those by then I kind of
got it and was like okay I'm doubling
back down in uber yeah I I was there in
the earlier days of that company coming
together and when Garrett camp and
Travis kalanick put their heads together
on something it's just like blank check
just do it yeah and it was the largest
Eric camp because that's that's a he he
seems to be getting no credit for the
formation of his company he is a quiet
Canadian as with most Canadians the
founder of StumbleUpon yeah I mean
StumbleUpon is the biggest traffic mover
short of Twitter I think I mean that
your preferred traffic it's just it's
just amazing I mean and I wish our
Investor and that company I'm not but
that guy comes up an idea every week and
what's cool about Garrett is he comes up
with an idea over drinks and then later
that night he goes home and he hires a
contract programmer to start working on
it so that's it's just amazing like he's
happy I step up all the time just to
really really gifted entrepreneur and so
uber was the kind of thing where I
remember some of the initial brainstorm
was when you know Garrett basically it
ran it out his own Lexus you know put it
out there so that his friends could use
the app and pulled NASCAR and got a
couple other cars on the system and and
they found Ryan Graves is an amazing
hustler to be the first GM and then yeah
Travis Travis did kind of the Evan
Williams and a Twitter thing where he
was like helping out but it was just so
compelling yeah the founder him was like
I just got to get closer I gotta get
closer I got it took over it just to go
it was just you know at the time he was
he was advising a bunch of companies and
just uber started dominating life it's
like I gotta get it